تعرضت له وسط مدينه دونيسك هذا القصف الذي
استهدف احدى المقرات المهمه الحكوميه هنا
بهذه المدينه ضمن القسط الذي تتعرضه
المدينه على طول اليوم هنا يمكن ان نشاهد
اثار الصاروخ او القذيفه التي استهدفت هذا
المكان وعمق هذه الحفره يشير الى قوه
الصاروخ الذي ضرب هذا المكان والذي احدث
هذه الخسائر في هذا المبنى الحكومي الامني
المهم والذي ادى الى تكسر الزجاج الزجاج
وكذلك الشظايا المتناثره على المكان ادت
الى احداث دمار في السيارات المتواجده هنا
لكن هذا الهجوم لم يسفر عن سقوط ضحايا ولم
يؤدي الى اصابه اي من الافراد القائمين
هنا او العاملين في هذا المبنى هذا ياتي
ضمن سياق هذا ياتي ضمن سياق الهجمات التي
تتعرض لها مدينه دنيتك هنا يمكن ان نشير
كذلك على ان بالاضافه الى هذا الهجوم في
نفس التوقيت كان هناك هجوم على مقربه
مقربه امطار من هذا المكان استهدفت
القذيفه مبنى سكني لكن لم تؤدي الى سقوط
ضحايا اذا ما تحدثنا عن مجمل القذائف التي
تنزل هنا على دنيا سكوا جميع المدن فيمكن
الحديث عن ما يقارب من اكثر من 200 قذيفه
وتؤدي في كثير من الاوقات الى سقوط جرحى
وكذلك الى تدمير للبناء التحتيه
نور الدين الجزيره